paul ronzheimer unser reporter in kiel
für sitzt zusammen mit wladimir
klitschko dem ehemaligen box-weltmeister
und die beiden können genau über dieses
thema sprechen über krieg und sport
thomas wir sind weiterhin hier in kiel
an einem ort den richtungslosen aufgrund
der sicherheitslage kommentar ist es
relativ ruhig draußen noch wir erwarten
aber eine harte nach möglicherweise
wollen aber darüber sprechen wladimir
klitschko was der sport tun kann und da
gibt es jetzt eine entscheidung die euch
hier in der ukraine freut was bedeutet
das was die ioc da gerade angestoßen hat
gerade ist vor
fünf minuten ist die offizielle
nachricht von der uci das
planerische teams sowie das verstanden
habe ist dass alles so schnell
werden dann nicht mehr unterstützung bei
der uci und der olympische sport alles
gestellt für internationale olympische
komitee dass die mannschaft nicht bei
den alle sportarten nicht teilnehmen
kann also saniert wird auch das jetzt
gibt es immer diesen satz den man in den
vergangenen jahren immer wieder gehört
hat sport ist nicht politik sport muss
von politik getrennt werden du sagst
nein sport ist auch politisch ist nicht
nur meine meinung dass alles politik in
dem sinne weil es wir leben in einer
gesellschaft wo eine mit dem anderen in
verbindung kommt
das ist der politisch wie wir es
verstanden haben sport ist auch sehr
politisch und das darf man nicht
unterschätzen und
eigentlich jede aktive teil der
gesellschaft kann auch wenn die politik
in den filmen cost to mit russischen
sportlern in kontakt was nimmst du var
aus russland wie dieser krieg gegen euch
gegen die ukraine dort wahrgenommen wird
ich habe ich habe
es gibt es geht letztendlich nicht um
nationalität dass da muss man auch
vorsichtig sein man kann nicht sagen
dass das die die russen sind schlecht es
geht um bestimmte regimes gibt um
bestimmte richtung bestimmte politik die
muss die leute für eigene zwecke und es
ist mehr drauf muss man nach mandaten
nicht sagen auf keinen fall man darf ich
sagen dass die nation schlecht ist aber
wenn es geht um politische richtung und
ein regime dann dann ist schon ganz klar
das war schon auch in die vergangenheit
auch in der geschichte so dass das die
leute einfach
greenwashing bekommen haben und dann
gewisse sachen gemacht haben die einfach
ja eigentlich nichts mit dem gehirn zu
tun haben was erwartest du neben den
olympischen sportarten lassen uns übers
boxen reden über den fussball reden über
diese ja
sportarten die besonders also ich habe
jetzt vor kurzem mitbekommen dass die
uefa
das ist schon auch ein gewisses städten
gewesen vor zwei tagen das mobile gerade
auch die teams nicht bei den
champions league spielen zu lassen uci
teams und es ist schon wirklich
nicht nur finanzielle sanktionen die man
so oft gehört hat in den vergangenen die
eigentlich keine wirkung gezeigt haben
jahrelang keine wirkung aber jetzt geht
es wirklich um alles es geht um alles es
geht um leben oder tod frieden oder
krieg so einfach wie gesagt
das sind andere sagen die muss man auch
verstehen sind schon hin und her aber es
geht um alles und deswegen wenn man
schon für frieden steht kämpft dann muss
man alles dafür geben alles oder nichts
alles und nichts sagst du glaubst du
dass das vladimir putin wirklich
beeindrucken kann was dort passiert oder
ist er in seiner eigenen welt
ich glaube es ist schwer in diese person
sich einzusetzen weil er wenn du
so lange herrscht und letztendlich
du hast schon mehrere sachen gemacht und
man man hat schon mit dem oft getroffen
das hat man auch gesehen direkt vor dem
griff direkt krieg vor dem angriff das
hat nichts gebracht
eigentlich und deswegen ich für mich ist
auch ein rätsel wie welchen einfluss
oder wie kann der einfluss werden um
diesen krieg zu stoppen du hast war die
mit putin war getroffenen der
vergangenheit wie hast ihn wahrgenommen
ich habe eben
2011 getroffen und er wirkte sehr
bodenständig und er hat mich angeht
werden besucht damals
und natürlich die ich verstehe auch wie
sehen die regieren kann man sagen ist
absolut
schlauch kann man sagen aber das was
gerade gemacht wird das was gerade
mit dem krise 1000 2014 man hat auch das
andere gesicht gesehen also sozusagen
ein wulff in so ein schafsfell
und wollte
moderator in berlin hat auch eine frage
eigentlich lade mir und ich gebe sie an
dich weiter thomas ja herr klitschko
paul mich würde interessieren wie
wladimir klitschko einschätzte dass
heute so viele menschen wir haben diese
dramatischen bilder vom bahnhof gesehen
in kiew so viele menschen die stadt
verlassen hat menschen die ja auch
gebraucht werden um kiew zu verteidigen
ihr sitzt vor der karte von kiew
die frage ist wie sehr die bilder die
bis heute gegeben hat dass viele
menschen jetzt raus fahren auch auf
tiere wie du diese bilder reagiert und
ob diese menschen nicht gebraucht werden
um die stadt zu verteilen nein
lassen wir uns nicht bieten lassen sie
uns mit die bilder reden
einen direkten angriff vor 3 stunden auf
die stadt aktiv was im nordosten der
ukraine wie sie befinden
und das sind schreckliche bilder
diesen zivilisten die in ihren gebeten
mit erstarrten häusern
explosion sieht man man sieht oppermann
sieht
gestorbenen babys
man sie zivilisten die sterben
und sinnlos
attackiert bombardiert die bilder sind
das wahre gesicht dieses krieges
natürlich hier kriegt ihre krieg
kreiert flucht bei den menschen es ist
eine sache aber die bilder die ich jetzt
von der stunde gesehen habe die sind
besetzt und von daher ja nur fertig das
sozusagen die restlichen zivilisten weg
worden aus den städten und tierställen
liquidierung auch für ständig ja wie ich
erwarte das gleiche wird ihm tief
passieren und anderen städten wie
eintragen und dann genauso gelegenheit
griff wer hat denn gedacht dass die
staaten die staat also wir werden gerade
nicht ähnlich einer militärischen
gebiete sondern die stadt wo menschen
leben
wird bombardiert wo ist die logik was
will man dann schaffen es
ist nur
das böse
was jetzt aus russland kommt und das
böse
was uns ukraine tötet
wladimir klitschko für die klaren worte
wir vielleicht zum abschluss gehen davon
aus du hast das angesprochen das ist
neuer angriffe geben wird auch auf 4 was
glaubst du wie die nächsten nächte tages
weil man hofft natürlich auf das beste
dezent die ukrainische kräfte zeigen
auch unglaublich
schnelligkeit beim lernen wie man das
land verteidigt und
man man hofft dass einfach wenig weniger
oder keine menschen weiter sterben
werden letztendlich man kann ein leben
nur einmal haben und nicht mehr
deswegen ich möchte in keinen staat
nicht nur in der ukraine auf diesen welt
die bilder sehen wie ich vorher schon
gesehen aber was ist passiert mehrere
explosion mehrere tote zivilisten kinder
frauen männer
einfach menschen die
sinnlos sterben weil
irgendjemand hat irgendwelche ambitionen
und über die politik knallhart aus
danke wladimir klitschko danke für die
klaren worte und damit zurück zu euch
nach berlin thomas